this book will make you first completely
hate humanity and then kind of fall in
love with it this book will make you
chase pain and this one will make you
want to ignore and completely deny it
this book will make you fiery passionate
about this one will make you completely
detached there is so much both emotional
and intellectual power contained in
books but i've found that specifically
reading philosophy books over the last
few years has genuinely changed my brain
and the way that i approach life the way
that i think and see myself and the
world and so today i wanted to share
four main ways that reading philosophy
books has changed me as a person number
one is lessening my anxiety through
having a free perspective shift in the
world and what i mean by this is that
for example if you have ever been on a
flight away from your hometown and
you've looked out of the window down to
the city and you can see basically
everything or if you've gone high up in
the mountains and you've looked down at
the city have you ever had this feeling
of kind of perspective changing where
you go i can't believe that in just this
tiny little space this is where i've had
so much anger so much pain so many tears
so much rejection so much fear so much
desire so much love
so many things have happened and once
you're so far away from it and you look
down at it it kind of feels almost so
much smaller and insignificant and i
always have had this feeling of going i
can't believe that i've gone through so
much pain for no reason it's all
contained in this tiny space and it
makes no sense and i feel as though this
is beautifully captured in one of my
favorite paintings which is the
enchanted castle which kind of shows
this moment of this lady who's left the
castle to think and i think that all the
issues that she might be facing within
the walls kind of completely change when
you're far away and this is why we have
this instinct i think to want to move or
detach whenever we're going through a
lot of pain or break up for any sort of
loss but this sort of physically
removing yourself from a situation or
looking down at the situation physically
is so difficult expensive and sometimes
impossible if you're having 3am terrible
thoughts you don't really have the
option of just going to the top of a
mountain and looking down and to gain
this like immediate perspective shift
but i feel as though through reading
philosophy i've kind of gained the
ability to do this just mentally to
myself so for example one of my favorite
philosophers michael allen singer talks
a lot about this ability to kind of step
out of yourself and look at the person
who's experiencing your life rather than
always being in that first person view
all the time and he describes this for
example when he says and here comes this
moment and the next and the next and the
next and what he's describing here is
this ability to gain perspective and
look at what's happening to you rather
than experiencing it which can be a very
valuable thing to do especially when
you're in a lot of pain this ability to
be completely detached not just from the
things around you but to be able to
sometimes be detached from yourself is
so liberating when you need it again
michael singer said the more you let the
world just be something you're aware of
the more it would let you be who you are
this ability to almost gain perspective
immediately is something that so many
philosophers have described and reading
a lot about it and these are the types
of books that i will reread two three
four five different times and i just
want to get this message in me as well
as possible and this perspective shift
has been absolutely life-changing and
lessening my anxiety when i need it
secondly those three books have changed
my brain is that they've shown me what
true freedom looks like and this freedom
of thought that you have in philosophy
is like absolutely nothing else i
remember the first time i read nietzsche
nietzsche nietzsche and i think it was
the genealogy of morals or beyond good
and evil and i remember being utterly
shocked and thinking oh my god are we
allowed to say this is he is this okay
how can we do this but then the more and
more i read about it the more i thought
that it was so entertaining so fun and
so liberating the thing about philosophy
is that the only rules are mathematical
rules so things just need to adhere to
logic so they need to make sense so that
we can all kind of understand what the
other person is saying but beyond that
you can say absolutely anything your
deepest darkest thoughts you can say out
loud you can question them you can ask
other people about them everything
absolutely everything is encouraged to
be said and to be spoken and it's so so
so beautiful it's almost a celebration
of all the different things that the
human mind can come up with and we'll
collaboratively discuss them attack them
support them just chat about them
recognizing that this is just an
intellectual conversation and this is so
so so much fun nietzsche himself said i
want things and my writings are another
and this ability to distinguish the
things that we say and the things that
we think and the things that we are
considering from ourselves is so so so
so important this made me realize and
appreciate that we are not our thoughts
because those things change all the time
and we are not our opinions because
again these are so malleable and it's so
liberating to realize that everything
that we've ever experienced or thought
or seen or done is just not who we are
and we have the ability to constantly
change this and we should be able to
discuss these whenever we want in
philosophy i think things have very
little consequences and they are praised
and celebrated just for existing and for
promoting conversation and for kind of
helping us live our lives in a more
entertaining way the next and very
important way that my brain has changed
is recognizing that it cannot be trusted
and i should definitely not trust myself
and my own thoughts richard feyman very
famously said the first principle is
that you must not fool yourself and you
are the easiest person to fool it's
actually quite shocking how
untrustworthy our own minds are and how
much we trust them at the same time so
for example if we take the voice in our
heads that we identify with and
externalize it for a moment and imagine
that yourself is a close friend of yours
and this close friend has been giving
you advice your whole life this friend
has been telling you who to date has
been telling you who to like who not to
like what people think about you what
job you should take what you should eat
what you should do all this advice has
been given from this external person
then the question is how often are they
right because in my case for example i
am very very wrong the ways that i think
people think about me the ways that i
think i think about people the feelings
and thoughts i have always change all
the time and i give myself some really
really bad advice sometimes so if i was
a friend and i next gave myself advice i
would probably go
i'm not sure if i can trust you or if i
had hired someone to be my advisor or my
consultant and that person was myself
they would be fired definitely because
their track record is not too good now
this is not to say that i think we
should not trust our minds i should
rather hire someone else to do things
for us this is not what i'm saying but i
think just recognizing that ourselves
are not that trustworthy and just
keeping this in mind in the background
is very informative but also very
liberating in a way eckhart tolle for
example said that i am never upset for
the reasons that i think i am and i
think there's this huge realization in
philosophy that we are separate from
ourselves and that our minds change and
cannot be trusted i think it's very
liberating to see my life in the way
that i'm constantly changing and i
strongly feel things that obviously will
change and that i'm in a constant state
of flux and i'm just as good at judging
myself and judging others than others
are at judging me and judging themselves
i don't know why i'm sometimes
functioning under the assumption that i
somehow have this better view of the
world than other people have around me
which doesn't make any sense i think
we're all on the same footing and i
think through philosophy you also
realize that people have always been the
same and they've been just as changing
and untrustworthy to themselves as they
are right now even eating early
philosophers three thousand two thousand
one thousand years ago they're facing
the same issues the same concerns the
same problems that we have today and
it's so amazing to be able to resonate
fully with what they're saying and we
are saying that we really just haven't
changed in nature almost at all and not
only that not only have our internal
instincts always remain the same but the
way that we view the world has
completely shifted so for example
nietzsche recognized that all good
things were once bad things every
original sin becomes an original virtue
and realizing just how much we've
changed our minds throughout humanity on
so many core essential values and
virtues shows that no rules or opinions
or thoughts or judgments are really set
in stone the only thing that remains
constant our natural instincts and the
way that we adapt and adjust to them is
constantly changing and that adaptation
and judgment just cannot be trusted so i
think this approach of viewing myself as
being sometimes very untrustworthy is
very very liberating and kind of takes
the pressure off a lot the thoughts i
can have either good or bad the
achievements or the losses that i have
sometimes i'm seeing that's a lot of
this is constantly in flux and therefore
should not be judged too much another
way that philosophy has changed my brain
is that it's given me access to this
adult mental gameplay which is just so
much fun what i mean by this is that for
example i think we have this stereotype
of children which is very true in that
they ask a lot of questions and they
always say why why why why why and at
some point in life we stopped doing this
but i don't think that instinct ever
goes away i think either we got told off
because i remember being told off
because my questions were inappropriate
or my questions were just too much or
they didn't have easy answers or their
answers would be problematic so i was
told to hush at some point when we're
growing up and then we realize that some
questions are a bit weird and we shut
ourselves down but this instinct of
wanting to know what's happening in the
world or just asking really big
questions of why are we here and why do
we need to do any of this or why do we
feel a certain way i feel that deep down
we all are genuinely philosophers and
this instinct and feeling just never
goes away this fascination with
ourselves and the world and people
around us and the whole existence of the
universe i think is just so essential to
who we are as people and realizing that
there is a space in the adult world
where you can safely do this when you
are encouraged to think about literally
anything and question anything and you
have access to this with so much
intellectual adult conversation it's
just so much fun philosophy has been a
space for me as an adult to ask those
big why questions that i stopped asking
as a child but i still am just as
fascinated by and although they don't
have definite answers they have quite a
few which are very interesting to
explore those of the discussions tend to
be really really fun as someone who
loves physics they're very similar to
that but you don't need to know as much
maths so for example you come up with a
theory of how humanity works or how the
world works or how systems work and you
come up with this as a formula and as
you would do in physics which is then
you need to test it in various different
situations and see if it holds true you
do the same thing in philosophy you test
it in various different groups and
various different examples and see if it
works and then someone else their job is
to kind of play devil's advocate and see
why this theory doesn't work or you need
to do it for your own theory and it's
just so much fun playing devil's
advocate is kind of one of my favorite
things to do and i know it's potentially
a bit annoying to other people but it
comes from a good place i promise but
it's just so interesting and engaging as
adults to have these sort of
conversations to test our theories to
see why things work in a very safe open
free environment where we recognize that
nothing matters we recognize that what
we say isn't exactly who we are we
recognize that sometimes we're just
saying things because they logically
make sense but we don't need to actually
believe them but we just want to test
where our mind goes and how reactions to
these things make us feel which is just
so beautiful so if you can get over the
slight pretentiousness of using the word
philosophy in general approaching these
sort of books and approaching these sort
of conversations is just so so so
interesting and i would recommend it to
absolutely everyone i'll link a few
books which are my absolute favorite
staple philosophy books below and you
can actually read the short form kind of
condensed versions of them if this video
is not sponsored by short form but um
it's a quick way to kind of get the main
gist of what these books have to say and
see if they are the right fit for you
and on the other hand if you feel as
though philosophical books might be a
bit too intense for you now another
great alternative is to watch the joys
of chance documentary on kirsty's dream
which are very kindly sponsoring this
video this documentary breaks summer
purchase to philosophy in a very
palatable and easy to understand way as
well as kind of ask the questions as to
whether fate or chance actually are
fundamentals of the universe and how our
existence is built around these truths i
would really recommend it as a great
first watch into the world of philosophy
and there will be a link in my
description which will give you a great
discounted currency stream if you want
to check it out using the link you also
get free access to nebula a platform
where a lot of educational creators like
me put our videos up for consumption
without ads so if you want to check that
out feel free but otherwise thank you so
much for spending this time with me i
hope you have a wonderful rest of your
day be count yourself and others and
don't believe everything you think
thanks bye